we are very excited about our next guest
actors Jimmy Smits and Amanda Warren
they play police officers in the new CBS
drama East New York Smith's is an Emmy
award-winning actor known for his roles
in NYPD Blue La law The West Wing and
Sons of Anarchy
he's done a whole lot and Warren has
starred in The Purge the leftovers and
Dickinson now she's playing Deputy
inspector Regina Haywood who's put in
charge of a police precinct in East New
York and Smith's plays her Mentor Chief
John Suarez in the clip you're about to
see they respond to a hostage situation
bombs like just went through all these
video footage
they say the electronic triggers a daisy
chain so one of those they all go he
won't give up the hostage and he's not
even talking to us eventually they're
going to war him to the window and snipe
him before he blows the place up he's
not talking it might be the only way
before we reach that conclusion I'd like
a shot at talking to
him I think I can reach this guy I gotta
say no Regina
it's time to let ESU to the job nobody
gets to make a bomb threat in this city
anymore expect to just walk away One PP
got to you they did I got Chiefs and
super Chiefs blowing up myself yes next
call is going to probably be the PC
ordering us to light them up
honestly I could watch you two talk all
day I mean you're so good Jimmy Smith
and Amanda Warren join us now the show's
terrific you guys are terrific together
in it uh and for Jimmy you you played a
lot of cops before in your life right a
lot of you people on TV once or twice uh
but this time's a little bit different
because you're in the neighborhood where
you real life Jimmy actually grew up
yeah it's like that kind of Never Say
Never well you know we Thrive as actors
to be versatile and I don't know about
having to talk about
revealing so much about yourself every
time you do a job but this meant a lot
to me because it's the neighborhood
where I had my Wonder Years you know
where I discovered theater and you know
had my first kiss and all that so you
were filming in an area where you had
your first kiss
you're welcome by the area yeah yeah
yeah I mean you know I get flushed yes
they get tired of hearing me talking
about oh God we do not did people get Al
Sharpton there I was in high school did
people in the neighborhood come up to
you not because you're actor Jimmy Smith
but because you're the guy who grew up
there I I've had a couple of people say
my mom went to high school with you or
uh I was at I was the kid at the
community action program that you worked
in during the summer so that's you know
I'm flushed with it it informs
everything else that I do on a
day-to-day basis but we're both New
Yorkers energized you know that area too
Amanda you know I do but I know the kits
Bay Area Manhattan a little better I
went to school in Gramercy went to NYU
Tisch ppas which is in the Theater
District as a vocalist and uh haven't
really looked back since yellow school
but where does you got this role without
auditioning how was that I don't know
because I don't know Jimmy how is it
no I was I was getting ready for another
show the upcoming season of Gossip Girl
where I play a meme mommy and and
basically I was just getting ready for
the the day's work the next day and I
had gotten the script told them that I
really enjoyed it and thought it was
different and the next week there was an
offer on the table and I said oh did you
know Jimmy was involved no I was the
first person cast Okay so he said oh a
test job yeah a test offer yeah a
producer session and no Amanda you have
this role it is yours to take and I
haven't really looked back since and I
was filming with Jamie Foxx a feature
coming up and it was just all a
whirlwind of of Dreams well they made a
good call yeah for sure uh Jimmy this is
not only a reunion to the place you grew
up for you uh it's also a reunion with
the executive producer of NYPD Blue
what's that like a lot of a lot of the
creatives that are that have been
involved in in both in La law and NYPD
Blue are involved in that and that there
was it was a comfort for me because
there's a shorthand between us and I
know where the heart is in terms of the
topic that we're dealing with in the
time that we're dealing with it in
there's a young creative Mike Flynn
who's with us who's you know giving
voice to that writer's room as well so
uh yeah with jazz and then Amanda you
put you had to physically prepare for
the role because there's a lot of
physicality in this character there is
and you post it on Instagram where you
go to the range and you're and you're
really getting ready yeah so I quite
enjoy shooting I had done it um on
occasion but now I do it on a monthly
basis now so it's um yeah the training
uh waking up early like you all for
those early calls going from the top to
the bottom of the call sheet um you know
you wake up you have an athletic energy
and you go in action and put your
explanation into action
cheating treating this job like an
athlete all right on a date we do the
same workout at 45. he's my insta friend
but before we go uh Jimmy I got
something special for you you mentioned
uh being exposed to drama uh for the
first time growing up in East New York
we found the Drama teacher uh who turns
you on to acting I know you gave up
football uh to take on this uh acting
thing and it's turned out pretty well I
got a message from him uh let's play it
oh no whoa hey Jimmy it's Mickey T your
old High School Drama teacher at
Jefferson High School and how ironic is
it now you're in a show called East New
York which is of course exactly the
place where we first used to work
together well I wanted to thank you for
quitting the football team all those
years ago in order to come and be in the
show that I was directing I think that
you made the right decision oh my God
Charlie things seems to have worked out
pretty well
still teaching and directing I'm at
Wagner College now but I can still
remember that shy awkward kid who showed
up to audition for the spring play I'm
glad you did
stay cool Smitty
oh Smitty
how did you know you wanted to act at an
early age when you could have done
football too I like Mr T that's nice
yeah I mean it wasn't only football it
was the neighborhood that we're shooting
is challenged in so many you know social
economic ways
with regards to healthcare there just
have been mentors
question on him Jimmy what does it mean
to you that he's he of course still
remembers you too yeah I mean he he he
exposed us to theater taking us to see
Broadway plays you know I remember
taking kids to see The Wiz and the the
light in their eyes when they you know
when that flame is lit it's a beautiful
thing yeah happen in East New York yeah
it's a beautiful story and you guys are
in a great show it's going to do
fantastic and you're on CBS by the way
I'm going to say that again Jimmy Smith
Warren thank you very much you can watch
East New York Sunday nights nine eight
Central right here on CBS and streaming
on Paramount Plus